Now, speaking of being down to just six
weeks since Joe Biden's inauguration,
we learned about something crazy yesterday. Donald
Trump. Now that he seems to slowly be accepting,
although he won't admit it privately, he seems
to be accepting that he lost to Joe Biden.
Trump is reportedly planning an absolutely bonkers
Inauguration Day stunt for January 20th. Now,
as you might remember from past
inaugurations, there's this tradition where
the incoming president allows the outgoing
president as they leave the White House
to fly wherever they're going. On Air Force One,
Barack Obama stood there and saw George W. Bush
and Laura Bush off on Inauguration Day into Marine
One helicopter and over to Air Force One to go,
I believe it was back to Texas. Donald Trump
likewise saw Barack and Michelle Obama off on
Inauguration Day onto the helicopter, bringing
them to Air Force One to go. I don't actually
remember exactly where they went. In fact, maybe
Barack Obama was I think he stayed in DC for
school purposes for his kids, but maybe he went to
Chicago initially or something like that anyway,
even though Donald Trump has still not
publicly acknowledged that Joe Biden won,
nor has he or anyone else said that he would
attend Joe Biden's inauguration on January 20th.
Trump is reportedly planning to fly to Florida
on Air Force One to do a competing event to Joe
Biden's inauguration. Can you imagine
anything more corrosive to democracy
beyond the things that Donald Trump has been doing
for the last month and for the last four years?
What could be more corrosive to democracy on
Inauguration Day for your successor than being
the outgoing president and holding a competing
rally likely to claim either that he actually won,
as Joe Biden is? Being inaugurated or to announce
his candidacy for twenty twenty four as Joe Biden
is being inaugurated, and part of the
reason that it's corrosive to democracy
is that it will continue to push a portion of the
country's voters to believe, as they already do,
that Joe Biden as of January 20th will be
an illegitimate president in some way. Now,
the truth could not be further from that claim.
Joe Biden not only won electorally with the same
allegedly landslide victory that Donald Trump
claimed for himself in 2016, but instead of
losing the popular vote by nearly three million,
as Trump did in 2016, Joe Biden won by six seven.
Is it maybe even eight million votes at this point
in time? So a former president being dropped off
by Air Force One on Inauguration Day for a rally
at which he will claim to be the real winner,
will not exactly project the stability of American
democracy. And in fact, it will project that much
of the opposite. Now, rally aside, an outgoing
president boycotting the incoming president's
inauguration. That alone would be bad enough. Now,
I don't think Joe Biden cares. Biden has already
said his concern is that it would be meaningful
to America for Trump to be there and really see
through a fully peaceful transfer of power. Biden
doesn't personally care and I really don't either.
The other wrinkle is, again, to
go back to the other possibility
that Donald Trump announces his 20 24 candidacy
on Inauguration Day. And these two things really
could be the same one. In other words, Trump might
fly to a rally in Florida at which he makes this
announcement while claiming he actually won and
it was stolen from him. Now, whatever happens,
what we can be sure of is No. One, Trump won't
behave like an adult on Inauguration Day.
And two, it will be really embarrassing for
the country. And three, his supporters will
absolutely love it. Trump will prove once again
that there is no floor to his petulant nature.
There's no too far for Donald Trump. And,
of course, part of the whole point would be
to take audience away from Joe Biden. Do you
think that if Trump does a January 20th rally
at the same time as the inauguration, do you think
CNN will cover both in a split screen? Will MSNBC
cover both in a split screen? I don't know. I
think the bigger question is, if Trump does this
doesn't even cover the inauguration. Does
Newsmax even cover the fact that there's a new
president being sworn in or do they only cover?
Trump's bizarre rally will eventually find out
what Trump is doing. We can rest easy knowing
that whatever the hell he's doing at noon on
January 20th, he will no longer be doing it as
president. And the other story that we're hearing
is that Donald Trump does indeed plan to go down
to Florida, to his resort for Christmas. And there
are rumors which we've heard for weeks now. There
are rumors that Trump will never come back to the
White House, that Trump is abandoning the White
House at Christmas time and won't even come back,
which would make irrelevant this entire idea of
flying out on Air Force One might still hold the
rally on Inauguration Day. Needless to say, the
next six weeks are going to be completely wacky.